[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Jean Ross vice
president of evangelism for amazing
facts hello friends how about an amazing
fact on June 21 1963 marine pilot Cliff
judkins was refueling in air on his way
from California to Hawaii when the
shadow valve on his f8 Crusader fighter
jet failed causing the tank's overflow
spilling fuel all over his plane flames
quickly engulfed his jet and Judkins
realized that he needed to eject as soon
as possible so he tucked in his legs and
pulled on the ejector handle but nothing
happened he then pulled the backup
firing handle and receipt but still
nothing his only choice now was an
old-fashioned bailout nobody had ever
bailed from an f8 Crusader before but
with a quick prayer he manually opened
the canopy and at 220 knots and 15,000
feet he was quickly sucked out of the
cockpit his troubles however were far
from over when he pulled his parachute
the little pilot chute deployed but the
main parachute remained unopened
Judkins fell nearly three miles straight
down into the Pacific striking the water
at over a hundred miles per hour but
amazingly survived with two broken
ankles a fractured pelvis and a
collapsed lung what helped his survival
was an event that occurred in his life
four years earlier after a car accident
Judkins had a spleen removed during
emergency surgery if it had not been
removed based upon the angle of impact
into the water it would have most
certainly ruptured and would have caused
his death
did you know friends that there is
another kind of surgery that can save
your life eternally
stay tuned for more as amazing facts
brings you this edition of Bible answers
live you're listening to Bible answers
live honest answers to your Bible
questions our phone lines are now open
if you have a Bible related question
call us at one eight hundred
that's one eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven now let's
join our host pastor Jean Ross hello
friends this is Bible answers live a
live in national interactive Bible study
we just delighted that you are tuning in
for this very important hour of the week
where we talk about the Bible and we
want you to be a part of this program if
you have a Bible related question this
is a good time to pick up your phone and
give us a call our phone line here to
the studio is 800 God's says that he's
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven we have a few lines still
open so there's a good time to call now
to get your question on tonight's
program I'm gonna give you that number
one more time so get ready here it is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven and we'll be mentioning that
number a little later on in the program
if you missed it I'm just delighted that
pastor Marshall Mackenzie is joining me
here in the studio he's gonna be working
the phones
pastor Mackenzie is one of the pastor's
on the amazing fax staff and Marshall
we're just delighted that you are here
but before we get to our questions this
evening why don't you open with the word
of Prayer that sounds good father in
heaven we thank you so much that we have
this opportunity to study your word
together to ask questions and to get
answers but we need your Holy Spirit to
lead and guide our conversations may you
truly be glorified and all that is
shared in Jesus precious and Holy Name
we pray amen amen
well past the mckinsey we opened the
program by talking about a gentleman
pilot by the name of cliff Judkins who
experienced quite the fall amazing about
three miles up across the Pacific
somewhere
his main parachute doesn't open but the
little pilot chute does open and he
comes flying down and makes impact on
the water at over a hundred miles an
hour they say about a hundred and ten is
what
estimate the speed that he actually hit
the water and for him to survive is one
thing and you know he broke both ankles
and you know he's hip a little bit but
nevertheless he survived and after the
fact when he was visiting with the
doctors and they were kind of looking
through what happened and how he
actually survived they found out that
because his spleen was removed four
years earlier based on the impact and
the angle of the water they were certain
that that would have caused his death
this mean would have ruptured so kind of
interesting he went through a very
difficult experience four years earlier
but now unknowing to him that actually
was an event that helped save his life
yes you know it was really amazing to me
as you read that story the different
shapes that God's grace takes in our
lives mm-hmm it doesn't just come in one
way all the time sometimes we may not
understand what's happening but God has
a reason and a purpose and and His grace
is very evident at each stage in our
life absolutely amazing in that story
yeah surgery many years before ended up
saving his life well you know after
reading that fact a verse came to mind
and I want to share it with you because
I think it's a very important verse and
it's a type of surgery you'll see in
just a minute a type of spiritual
surgery that can actually save our lives
for eternity the verse that I'm thinking
about is Ezekiel chapter 36 and verse 26
and it's God speaking God says I will
give you a new heart and I'll put a new
spirit within you I will take the heart
of stone out of your flesh and give you
a heart of flesh in essence a heart
transplant is what God is offering a
spiritual heart transplant in order for
us to survive the events that are coming
on the earth before Jesus comes we know
there's gonna be a time of trouble as we
read about in the Book of Daniel we need
to have that spiritual heart transplant
in order for us to be prepared for
what's coming but then the promise of
course is when Jesus comes we get caught
up to meet him in the air and we with
him forever
throughout the long ages of eternity
here with God and with those that love
him and God wants to give this heart
transplant to anyone and everyone who
comes to him in faith and ask amen and
you know we have a book that deals with
the theme of what do I have to do in
order to have God transform my heart to
change my life it is a great read
called three steps to heaven and this is
our free offer anybody who wants to
learn more about this important subject
just give us a call on our resource
phone line and you can ask for our free
offer tonight it's called three steps to
heaven and we'll be happy to send that
to you for free
so let me give you the number this is
our resource phone number and the name
of the book again is three steps to
heaven the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven that is the resource phone number
808 three five six seven four seven you
can ask for the book three steps to
heaven I'll be able to get that out to
you right away in the mail so you'll be
able to read that if you have a Bible
question the phone line here to the
studio with your Bible question tonight
is eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven eight hundred
four sixty three seven two nine seven
now pastor Mackenzie I believe we have a
email question that came in from one of
our listeners so I think we'll start the
program with that we do pastor Ross this
is that question the Bible says Jesus
was in the ground like Jonah three days
and three nights
considering how days were thought to
begin and end at sundown when did he die
well that's a good question you know we
often get people asking that and it's
based upon a verse that you read in
Matthew chapter 12 and it's verse 40
Jesus was talking to the religious
leaders and this is what he said and I'm
gonna read it it says for as Jonah was
three days and three nights in the belly
of the great fish so will the Son of Man
be three days and three nights in the
heart of the earth now a lot of people
think of the heart of the earth and
immediately they think well that must be
referring to the tomb but no in the
scriptures did we read of the heart of
the earth
meaning tomb or grave matter of fact
when we read in scripture about the
earth and the heart of the earth we read
about the prince of this earth or the
power of this earth and it's referring
to the devil so what Jesus is referring
to here when he says three days and
three nights he's talking about Christ
being in the power in the clutches of
the devil meaning God's protection the
father's wrist protection was being
withdrawn from Christ and that began on
Thursday evening right after the Last
Supper with the disciples after Judas
went to betray Jesus Christ began to
feel that separation from his
we have the story they in the garden of
gethsemane with Jesus prayed father if
it is possible let this cup pass from me
nevertheless not my will but thy will be
done so your Thursday evening and Friday
evening and Saturday evening that Christ
is in essence in the clasp of the enemy
and Jesus bore our sins and died in our
place so it's not talking about the
grave here when it talks about the heart
of the earth it's referring to Christ
under the or being vulnerable you might
say to the powers of the enemy kind of
like the experience that he was going
through and when that started in and
when absolutely he started bearing our
sons on Thursday evening going through
that experience you know we do have a
book that pastor Doug wrote on the
subject is called the sign of Jonah and
for anybody wanting to study the subject
further we'll be able to send you that
book just ask for it it's called the
sign of Jonah and the number to call is
883 five six seven four seven again you
can ask the book called the sign of
Jonah and we'll be happy to send that to
anybody who calls and asks well marshal
who do we have first on the phone lines
the Wheeling pastor Ross we have Sandra
from Calgary Alberta calling in Sandra
Sandra are you there
you're on Bob hi good evening how are
you tonight I'm great how are you doing
very well thank you are you both and
your question tonight so it's more to do
with first John 3:9 whoever has been
born of God does not sin for his sin
remains in him and he cannot sin because
he has been born of God yes so is this
true does this happen like is this what
being born-again truly means yes yes
sure there are three parts to I
experience of salvation I'm gonna go
through it quickly with you and now I'll
be more specific on this verse the first
phase is when we come to Jesus we
confess our sins and by faith we receive
his forgiveness and the theological term
that's often used for that experience is
called justification where we are
accepted by God because of what Jesus
did for us we accept it just as if we
have never sinned
but after we come to Jesus and we
receive His grace he also gives us of
his spirit and the Holy Spirit begins to
work within us to transform us to
empower us to set us free from sin and
sanctification is the work of a lifetime
it's not something that happens
instantaneously but as we learn to
depend more and more upon Christ and we
trust more in His grace in his power he
transforms our characters we experience
that spiritual heart transplant as
mentioned and we become more and more
like Jesus reflected more and more and
then the third phase of salvation is
glorification that happens at the second
coming when these mortal bodies put on
immortality so when it says those who
are born of God they do not sin now it's
not saying that we don't occasionally
make a mistake for we all sinned and
fall short of the glory of God as the
Bible says but when we come to Jesus and
by faith we claim his power and His
grace we have the privilege of being set
free from the control of certain sins
that have controlled us for example when
an alcoholic comes to Jesus and receives
His grace by faith not only he's
forgiven but he receives power to resist
alcohol and you know we hear wonderful
testimonies of people who have been
delivered from certain addictions by
exercising faith in Jesus so that is the
power of God working within the person
but it doesn't mean that there's no
further growth that they experience but
as God reveals to them in need and they
confess God gives them the victory so
it's an ongoing experience as long as we
our body in Christ we might not be where
we want to be spiritually but by God's
grace we shouldn't be where we started
there should be progression in our life
yes this almost sounds like it's saying
though that that we reach a point where
we will no longer sin I guess yeah as we
abide in Christ sins that once
controlled us cease to control us they
don't have any more power over us and we
become more and more reflecting Christ's
character I know it's a verse that can
be a little hard yeah at first we
and you know we got to kind of look at
some of the other verses on the subject
sanctification because that's what is
being emphasized yeah but the Apostle
John is as we abide in Christ
you know Jesus puts it this way John 15
he abides in me and I in him bears much
fruit he says without me you cannot do
anything so as we learn to abide in
Christ we receive more power and sin
loses its hold on the believer as they
trust in God eventually all sin
absolutely yes I'd like to freeze you
completed that's right
sorry the Lord delivered me for many
addictions in my past too and but yet
you know I still struggle with certain
sins today so doesn't mean that I won't
never have victory over those areas no
absolutely we have the promise that as
we trust in him he will finish the good
work that he has begun so I don't want
anybody to did get discouragement they
call this just no whack and gaining the
victory over this with God all things
are possible we didn't need to learn to
trust him even more well thank you for
your call Sandra good question very
important question who do we have next
we have Robert from Boston Massachusetts
Robert you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi Robert hi gentlemen the
question tonight is who in your opinion
is the restrainer the restrainer now can
you give me a little example of the
reference that you are holding back Oh
something okay well he has to be taking
away taken away before yes so there are
two restraining powers that you can read
about are in the Bible there is a
prophetic sense and then there's the
spiritual sense let me begin with a
spiritual revelation chapter seven talks
about four angels holding back the four
winds of strife that the wind should not
blow up on the earth or upon the sea
until the servants of God have been
sealing their foreheads now there's four
angels there in Revelation symbolize the
agents of God good angels are holding
back the powers of the devil to bring
total chaos upon the earth but there is
another restraining power that I think
you're referring to where Paul talks
about he
that restraints now will be taken out of
the way and it's talking about the rise
of the Antichrist power that you read
about that Paul refers I think it's
Thessalonians I think more you can look
that up for me
in that case Paul is referring to pagan
Rome it was during the time of the
Empress Nero Diocletian and others who
were holding in check the rising up of a
power a religious political power during
the Dark Ages which would actually bring
persecution and gods upon God's people
and that religious power is sometimes
referred to as the Antichrist power so
depending upon the context of the
passage that you're reading it could
refer to several things and the diverse
you're referring to second Thessalonians
two six seconds long what did you say
that for us it says and now you know
that what is restraining that he may be
revealed in his own time right the
Antichrist power correct for the mystery
of lawlessness is already at work only
he who now restrains will do so until he
is taken out of the way right and a
number of scholars see that as being
pagan Rome under the Emperor's until the
conversion of Constantine in 313 she
passed for us and that wouldn't have any
reference to a contemporary times would
it well you know I think revelation 7
definitely relates to our time we're
talking about angels holding back the
winds of strife and I think in a very
real sense God in His mercy is allowing
us to have the freedoms that we now have
so that we can preach the gospel and
share the good news with as many people
as we can but we do know that before
Jesus comes revelation or all the Daniel
chapter 12 verse 1 talks about a time of
trouble it's when those four angels let
go and this Antichrist power will again
arise in a persecuting fashion and that
is yet in our time even in the future
terrific thank you so much for your
guidance absolutely thank you for your
call Robert you know by the way we do
have a study guide and amazing facts and
we'll be happy to send that to you if
you just call and ask the number is 883
five six seven four seven and the study
guide is called who is the Antichrist we
get right into it there then I'm gonna
call 883 five six seven four seven you
can answer the study guide called who is
the Antichrist we'll be happy to send
that to anybody who calls it
asks our phone line here to the studio
if you have a Bible question looks like
we got two more lines open friends good
time to give us a call now if you want
to get your question on the first half
of the program it's eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven eight
hundred four six 372 97 pastor Ross our
next question is from Rob Charlotte
North Carolina Rob you're on the air
with Bible answers live well my question
is basically Zechariah 5 chapter five
verse five three Neven and it's talking
about this woman that's in a basket and
I just want you to elaborate on it a
little bit yes well let's look at a few
verses now you're thinking zechariah
chapter five with their specific when
you're talking about doctor r chapter
five particularly verse five six seven
all right let me read that for our
listeners a number of folks are driving
the car it says then the angel who
talked with me came out and said to me
lift up your eyes now and see what is
this that goeth forth so I asked him
what is it any acid it is a basket that
go with forth and he also said this is
the resemblance throughout the earth
verse seven says here is the lead disc
lifted up and this woman sitting inside
the basket then he said this is
wickedness and he thrust her down into
the basket and threw the led the lid
over its mouth so in Bible prophecy and
of course a karai's a prophetic book in
Bible prophecy we have a number of
symbols the first symbol that's very
prevalent in Scripture is the symbol of
a woman a woman in Bible prophecy
prophecy can represent a church in
Revelation chapter 12 you have a
description of a pure woman which
represents the true church and in
revelation 17 you have a description of
a corrupt woman that represents an
apostate church or wickedness and in
Zachariah a woman is sometimes referred
to as the nation of Israel when they are
true to God that described as the Bride
of Christ but when they are pasta sized
they are described as a wicked woman so
here in the symbolism of the vision of
the woman in a basket it is were talking
about wickedness
especially in the guise of religion and
it does have a prophetic application
because we know that the opposition to
the truth both in the time of Israel in
the time of Christ and especially in our
time comes from a religious institution
from a church that claims to be the
Bride of Christ but in reality she is
spreading wickedness upon the earth now
the basket is interesting too because
often bread was carried in a basket
that's where you'd store your bread
bread in the Bible is a symbol of the
Word of God the way that wickedness is
pushed back is through the preaching of
the word and that's the symbol of the
lid placed upon it so our weapons of
warfare is the Word of God one more
quick question sure quickly I've been
listening you guys why is it that in the
earth making new mankind humankind has
to eat from the tree of life to stay
alive but it doesn't seem like the
Angels have to eat from the tree of life
to stay alive well good question you
know when it comes to the eating of the
fruit of the tree of life in the new
earth or even in heaven there the tree
of life is in heaven
the eating of the fruit of the tree is
an exercise of our faith in God that he
is the one sustaining giving life all
life is a depend upon God in the earth
made new if you happen to skip one month
fruit from the tree of life you're not
going to start growing weak and die but
the eating of the fruit is a
demonstration of our confidence in God
our trusting in him as being the
sustainer as the one giving us life well
know the Angels also exercise faith in
God to sustain them but I think the tree
of life is unique in our experience as
humans here on the earth the angels are
a different test but they do demonstrate
their faith in God the tree is our
exercising of faith in God that he's the
one that stands us and gives us life and
again the Bible doesn't tell us for sure
you know obviously angels have freedom
to choose and we have a third of the
Angels that chose to rebel against God
they also have something they do that
exercises faith in God and their
obedience to him okay yeah no that's a
good question
I
know what they do but we know the trees
for us thanks Rob good question who do
we have next
all right our next question is from Jeff
Elbert Albuquerque New Mexico and he's
looking at revelation 1 into this is
there we go
Jeff you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi good evening thank you
for taking me a call yeah I want to make
this quick question it's only had three
minutes
sure first I want to reference Genesis
1:14 that God created the lights in the
firmament for science for seasons and
for days and years now in Revelation
12:1 and 2 there was a bichon and they
were appeared a great wonder in the sky
a woman clothed with the Sun and the
moon under her feet and upon her head a
crown of blood and she's being with
child cried yes yeah sure now on
September 23rd 2017 this this addition
is going to literally appeared in the
sky the constellation bill go is going
to be in the sky with the Sun on her
head and the moon on her feet and
Jupiter or in her belly actually it's in
her belly right now but on September
23rd it's going to come out of there and
at her head there is real constellation
that has 9 stars but because of the
Venus Mars and Mercury that will make it
12 all right well good a fulfillment
sure a revelation 12:1 and 2 ok and
according to to the Tuda you to the
Jewish people
yeah 2017 is pointing towards the
generation from the time they got that
installed back in 1947 to 2017 it's it's
70 years and which is one generation
all right well Jeff let me try to let me
try to say a few things about this
before we run out of time coming up to
our break here a good question yes in
Revelation chapter 12 you have a
description of a woman standing up on
the moon she has a crown of 12 stars and
woman in Bible prophecy represents a
church now it is interesting that the
stars revealed to us the handiwork of
God and some have seen some connection
between the plan of redemption God's
plan for mankind as revealed in the
stars or at least the constellation of
stars to be half but if you look in
Revelation chapter 12 that prophecy had
a literal fulfillment at the time of
Christ the woman represents the church
the 12 stars represent the leadership of
the church the number 12 is significant
in Bible prophecy represents the church
of 12 tribes the Old Testament 12
apostles of the new and it says she's
with child about to give birth and her
child is a male child that's caught up
to God and to his throne that is
definitely a symbol that has reference
to Jesus and then the church is
persecuted for 1260 years and she flees
into the wilderness that's referring to
the the Dark Ages when the church was in
hiding so it's got a definite
fulfillment of representing God's people
at the end of time and could there be
some connection with the constellation
of the stars you know maybe but I think
there's a clearer explanation for these
prophecies if we allow the Bible to
interpret itself does that hopefully
that makes sense Jeff you know we do
have a study guide dealing with that
called the Bride of Christ and I think
you'll find it very interesting kind of
goes into Revelation chapter 12 in more
detail and helps to identify some of
those symbols that we have you know I
think we might have time for one more
quick caller here before the break who
do we have next
we've got Aaron from Carmichael
California Aaron you're on the you're on
the air with Bible answers live Aaron
we've got just a couple of minutes hi I
just had a question in regards to
original sin because I've talked with
some friends who don't believe in
original sin or the concept of it okay
so I was just wondering
other than Romans chapter 5 I don't know
really where else to point yeah well you
know first of all probably need to
define what do we mean by original sin
there's probably several definitions we
reckon
is that because of Adamson we're all
born with a propensity towards evil but
we are not saying that we were born with
guilt meaning a tiny baby that is born
it might be self sainted and we learned
that his parents fairly quick but the
child a newborn baby is not guilty of
sin because it doesn't know the
difference between right and wrong
so we born with a bent towards sin and
we need to experience the rebirth
experience and experience God's grace
and then we are born again and we have a
new nature so we share in the
consequences of Adam's sin but we don't
share in his guilt we get our own guilt
based upon our own actions and our own
words and the beads that we do so you
know that's a more correct understanding
of sometimes when you think of original
sin so it's not the guilt that we get
from Adam but it is the nature of the
bent towards them well friends you can
hear the music playing there in the
background we're coming up on a mid-show
break so don't go away we got another
half an hour of Bible questions a good
time to give us a call 804 6 3 7 2 9 7
we'll be right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
amazing facts has impacted man
I praise God for amazing facts amazing
facts actually did have an impact is
full process getting to Maryam today I
[Music]
began reading the Bible I got baptized
into Anna's dead I realized that there
had to be more the light is really doing
there's a life that he's given this
message was so powerful I swear he goes
amazing facts more than 45 years of
proclaiming God's message around the
world and in the logo pops across
amazing facts presents I've listened to
a lot of different ministers but he was
this was the first time that he's
actually saying something where I had to
grab my Bible and actually pick it up
and I've never heard this before let me
let me look through and find this that I
just couldn't get enough and so I
started doing Bible space every single
one of these guys started being changed
including myself my question was why did
that happen to me God the Lord was able
to reach out and I actually saw him as a
father I lost everything and that was
when I realized that it was God missing
in my life
I went to a prophecy seminar which
knocked me out this message was so
powerful and so irrefutable notice when
this is real this is this is amazing
[Music]
every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live
[Music]
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call
[Music]
hello friends yes this is a live
international interactive Bible study
and if you like the Bible well yet the
right place if you're like talking about
the Bible will give us a call on our
resource I actually on our phone number
here to the studio I'll tell you about
another resource number in just a minute
but the phone line here to the studio
with your Bible question looks like we
got four lines open 800 463 seventy to
ninety seven 800 460 372 97 and working
the phones this evening is pastor
Marshall Mackenzie you know Marshall
we're just talking during the break
there about one of the caller's asked
about angels and how the angels gonna
eat of the Tree of Life you brought up a
good point I guess there's nothing
stopping them from eating because we do
have examples in the Old Testament
that's right of angels eating Abraham
specifically came to mind when the
angels actually came to him before they
went on to Sodom he actually fed them
and they said and they participated and
they ate so it appears as though angels
candy but I don't think they have to eat
because they're not governed by the same
laws that we're governed by and of
course we're gonna be governed by some
different laws when we get to heaven
it's I'm gonna be the same these mortal
bodies put on immortality the Bible says
so things are gonna be a little
different up there but it was a good
question about angels and the Tree of
Life all right well let's go to our next
caller who do we have we have Katie from
Glendale California Katie you're on the
air with Bible answers live and pastor
John Ross thanks Holden I have a
question regarding my husband you know
he's he's a weakness is gambling and you
know he has to drive me to Reno Nevada
because there is a clinic there where
they treat Lyme disease which I am
suffering from so you know how Reno Aces
like Las Vegas he told me he doesn't
gamble but I know he does am I
responsible for his behavior because he
drives me to Reno no you not responsible
no you're not responsible for his
behavior you're responsible for your
behavior and you know based upon the
medical needs that you need you have to
go there to get treatment I think you
want to keep encouraging him you know
gambling is attempt
and it can become an addiction and so I
think you're doing the right thing to
try and encourage him to stay away from
that but ultimately each person makes
their own choice and you know you'd be
the best example you can be you don't
want to be a nagging spouse but you want
to share your concerns and then just put
them in God's care and pray for them be
the best example you can but you're not
responsible for the decisions that a
spouse or a family member makes each
person makes those decisions
independently
yeah I'm just concerned I know I know
it's this Christian should not go to
gambling you know right it's not a good
idea I cannot I cannot stop him
I just have to pray for him that's the
best thing you can do you know sometimes
the hardest people for us to witness to
are those who are closest to us our
family members and yeah that's where we
want to intercede with prayer and just
to place them in God's hands and Trust
for his leading and guiding well Katie
thank you for your call and yes pray for
your husband as I know there are many
listening who might find themselves in a
similar situation they do in our next
call is evening is David from Queens New
York David you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi David
and your passion this evening okay John
chapter three verse one
concerning the statement that's made
there yes let me read it for those who
are listening it says behold what manner
of love the father has bestowed upon us
that we should be called children of God
therefore the world does not know us
because it did not know him do you have
any practical tips to have that
literally apply that like I understand
it means we need to appreciate in a
sense the amount the extent of love that
God has for us for life is there any way
to make that practical good question all
right how do we come to appreciate or
know the love of God even more well you
know it's more than just an Internet
sheíll understanding of what happened
there are many people that recognize
Jesus as being the son of God and that
he came and he died on the cross for our
sins and receive forgiveness through him
and yet it doesn't move them it doesn't
lead to a life of willing obedience and
I think the best thing we can do to
follow the admonition that John gives us
in John first John chapter three verse
one is to spend time contemplating the
life of Christ and one of my favorite
books is actually written by John it is
the Gospel of John where you can look at
the life of Jesus and it's a good
practice for every Christian to spend
some time every day in contemplation of
the life of Christ you know take a
teaching of Jesus spend a few moments
reading a parable or a miracle that
Jesus performed or some occurrence in
his life that's recorded in the Gospels
take time to meditate upon that and
study it and and pray about that and as
we behold Christ and the great love that
was demonstrated in his life there will
be a change that'll occur in our hearts
and lives it's the Spirit of God that
moves upon us so that's why the verse is
behold behold means to look to consider
to understand and so as we take time
every day in contemplation of the life
of Christ we will experience more and
more love of God and it is it is
exhaustless it's a it's a fountain that
never ends the more we learn the more we
see the more we come to know him and
love him and that's very good question
very practical I was just gonna say that
following up with what you're talking
about you know we see evidences of God's
love every day the fact that we have
breath the fact that we can move that's
very practical from a day-to-day basis
in relationship to the love of Christ so
as we're learning from the Word of God
we're seeing it played out on a day to
day basis absolutely because really you
know I'm gonna mention a book that I
don't mention this book too often but
you know there is a book on the life of
Christ that has just been a great
placing to me I already mentioned the
Gospels and you can't beat those but
there is a book by the name of desire of
Ages and I believe you can actually find
it online for free and it is just a
fantastic book on the life of Christ it
actually takes those passages in the
Gospels kind of goes through it presents
it in a way that you can really
sort of grasp it and understand it and
see in your mind's eye the occurrences
so I would encourage anyone check out
the book called desire of Ages you can
find it online and I I trust it will be
a blessing it's been a blessing to me
yeah I like to read that from time to
time and kind of just helps it helps me
in my understanding of God's great love
thank you for your call David appreciate
that
that opens up another phone line if you
have a Bible question the number is 800
four six three seven two nine seven
that's 800 God says 460 372 97 pastor
Ross our next question is from Rick Fort
Lauderdale Florida has an interesting
question Rick you're on the air with
Bible answers live what is your question
oh good evening pastors hi ray it says
in the Bible John the Baptist came
eating locusts and wild honey are the
locusts the fruit that is locust or is
that not just like grasshoppers
well you know believe it or not
grasshoppers falling the clean category
of the Old Testament so if you have an
inkling for grasshoppers do you go right
ahead I mean you create it but you know
I don't think John the Baptist could
really sustain himself for a long period
of time eating grasshoppers because you
know it says he's in the desert and back
in Bible times in that region there
would be these swarms of locusts that
would come through but there wouldn't be
year around so you could kind of feast
on locusts for a couple months and then
you'd be you know starving for the rest
of the year but there is a tree that has
a pot like beam that you can live on you
can eat it and you can cook it in
different ways and that was also
referred to as the locust being and a
number of Bible scholars feel like
that's really what's being referred to
there not grasshoppers jumping around
more the fruit not the insect it was
this kind of being like pod fruit type
type thing on a tree there and and it's
still you can still see them out there
today they they in that same area with
John the Baptist was preaching perfect
thank you so much all right thanks for
Col Rick appreciate it
who do we have next we have Kerry from
Royal Oaks Michigan and Kerry you're on
the line with Bible answers live hello I
just want to say thank you for taking my
call I appreciate it so much
you're welcome thanks for calling Kerry
this is my first time talking with you
guys and my question
that right now I know that the world and
everything around it's just so overly
confused and that I'm actually starting
to learn you know the beginning stages
of the Bible and I mean I've read
through it and read through it and read
through it and I know that some of the
verses do confuse me a little bit but
the question that I'm stemming from is I
just want to know like what can be some
verses that can help assure me and be
able to make me feel that you know that
the Lord is present and you know I know
he's there but you know there are times
where I go to bed feeling like oh my
gosh you know I have all the stress
anxiety because I do suffer from you
know anxiety and depression and there
are times where I'm just like okay well
what can I do to help to help alleviate
that and what verses can I read or help
me a very good question you know we need
to feast upon the Word of God because
that gives us spiritual nourishment just
like we need to eat good food in order
to be physically healthy you know first
a couple verses will give you here in
just a moment but let me begin with I
think an important principle the Bible
says we walk by faith not by sight and
that means that we are to trust in the
Word of God in the promises found in the
scriptures and not to the way we feel
because our feelings change our feelings
change based on circumstances our
feelings change based on what somebody
might say or do to us but the Word of
God never changes the God the love of
God is constant it's never ending so no
matter how we feel God still loves us
and he still promised to be with us the
Bible says Jesus said to his disciples I
will never leave you nor forsake you he
said I'll be with you to the very end of
the age meaning the end of the world so
God has promised to be with us so when
you feel discouraged don't think that
God doesn't love you anymore or that
he's abandoned you the thing to do is
spend time in prayer with him and say
Lord I am just feeling really down and
you know the nice thing about God is you
can't overburden him sometimes the
family member when our hearts are
breaking or we stressed and we
them or sometimes you don't want to talk
to family members because you don't want
to burden them with our problems but you
can't burden God he knows the end from
the beginning and he invites us to come
to him to lay all I cares at his feet
and and trust him and you know there's
been many times in my life where I've
been frustrated overwhelmed or something
and I've taken to the Lord in prayer and
and I spent some time just talking to
him as I would to a friend and at the
end of that prayer you know it's as if a
weight has been lifted off my shoulder
and I think you know what it's it's not
that bad I can claim the promise of God
so I want to encourage you to walk by
faith not by sight take God at these
promises and then communicate with him
through prayer tell him everything that
troubles you and ask him to give you a
peace and the assurance of his love and
then move forward in faith believing
that he'll answer that prayer I think
marshal you've got some some good Bible
promise verses there yeah I know we
don't have a lot of time to cover them
but just just a couple Isaiah 26:3 talks
about how if we trust in him he keeps us
in perfect peace yeah whose mind is
stayed on thee that's Isaiah 26:3
also Isaiah 41:10 is one of my favorites
mm-hmm
it says fear not for I am with you be
not dismayed for I am your God I will
strengthen you yes I will help you I
will uphold you with my righteous right
hand a wonderful promise that is right
God's gonna strengthen us God's gonna
uphold us with his right hand let me say
one thing he just brought something to
mind talking about that right arm you
know in the Bible the right arm of God
is often associated with him defending
his people the right arm was the arm in
which the sword was carried for a
soldier in the Old Testament and it
brought deliverance so God will deliver
us from our foes as we learn to trust in
him
so you know another thing you might want
to do carry is you know find a good
Bible promise book they're available at
a Christian bookstore and they just list
Bible promises for different situations
and circumstances and you can actually
look up in that book topics like
discouragement you can see some
wonderful Bible promises to help in
times of discouragement or fear or
whatever it might be
matter of fact we just did a Bible
promise book
relax you can look at their Bible
promise book carry and there's
lots of promise you know what we mention
an important point in fasting Mackenzie
Kari if you are not familiar with the
amazing facts website you need to take a
look just amazing facts dot o-r-g there
is such a wealth of Bible information
there videos you can watch stuff you can
read Bible study didn't even do a great
resource and you know if you want to
just fill your mind with spiritual truth
that's a good place to go thank you for
your call Kerry I think we're ready for
our next caller we are this is Phil from
Old Bethpage New York Phil you're on the
air with Bible answers Alive yes loud
and clear yeah first of all so you got a
great show I mean you really know your
stuff but you're speaking common-sense
terms I think you get it just right Wow
praise the Lord thank you I think it's
something about which there is
disagreement even among prominent
evangelicals my question is in order for
the third Advent to take place to be
possible is it necessary that there be
for the second Advent rather is it
necessary that there be a third Jewish
temple or is it Jesus himself is there a
temple no good question all right
is the temple going to be rebuilt in
Jerusalem or does it need to be rebuilt
in Jerusalem of course you know that
currently on the ancient site where the
Jewish temple used to be there is a
mosque
yeah all right you've been there it is
the second most holiest I guess shrine
or mosque to the Muslim community so you
know in order for them to build a temple
there they're gonna have to do something
with that mosque and you can just
imagine the backlash okay yeah they
brought bulldozers in there to move that
there'd be yeah they'd be warm but far
as the Bible goes does the temple have
to be rebuilt in Jerusalem the answer is
No
well the temple be rebuilt maybe but
it's not critical for Bible prophecy let
me explain in the Bible there are five
types of temples five types of temples
I'm gonna go through it quickly the
first is the heavenly temple according
to the book of Hebrews Jesus is a high
priest and he's ministering in the
heavenly temple one that is built by God
not by me
so there's a temple in heaven then there
was the earthly temple and when I say
the earthly I'm talking about the one
that Moses built in the wilderness the
one that Solomon built and the one that
was rebuilt after the 70 years of
Babylonian captivity I called it the
earthly temple that was the one that
Jesus entered into that was the one
there at the time of Christ it was
eventually destroyed by the Romans in 70
AD I call that the earthly temple but
there's three others and the three
others are very important
jesus said speaking of himself destroy
this temple and in three days I will
raise it up again I mean Christ was
talking about himself the next temple
that we find in the scripture is the
individual the Bible says no you're not
that your body is the temple of the Holy
Spirit so individually we are the temple
of God the Holy Spirit is dwelling
within us and then the final temple that
we read about in the New Testament is
the church we're all living stones put
together in the temple of God now here's
the point of the whole temple the reason
why there's even a temple why God told
Moses to build a temple in the Old
Testament was so that he could dwell
amongst these people that's the purpose
of the temple why did God need a temple
in order to dwell amongst these people
it's because of sin that's why you have
the sacrificial system that was sainted
in the temple so the sacrifice took care
of the sin problem so that God could
dwell amongst his people because if God
came to dwell amongst his people without
a temple the people would have been
consumed because of their sin now the
purpose of the temple is the same the
heavenly sanctuary the earthly sanctuary
the individual why is the Holy Spirit
dwelling within us well it's to take
care of the same problem in our hearts
and lives Jesus came he died on the
cross to take care of the same problem
so that we can be forgiven and dwell
with God forever the purpose of the
church in the world today is to preach
the gospel so that the sin problem can
be taken care of so that God can dwell
with these people so that's the the
supreme purpose of the temple and you
know sometimes people look at an earthly
temple and they think that a physical
building has to be rebuilt when God
wants us to understand the deeper fuller
understanding of what the temple is all
about it is God cleansing a people on
the earth so that when he comes his
character can be reflected through his
people so will the temple be rebuilt in
Jerusalem you know I don't know maybe
maybe not but it's not critical to
Bible prophecy okay that was a brilliant
answer absolutely brilliant
and I do thank you so very much all
right well thank you for your call Phil
that opens up another phone line and who
do we have next
we've got Ronald from Rialto California
Ronald you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi Ronald oh hey how you
doing tonight I just started reading the
Bible great in Matthew 12 verse 31 okay
whoever speaks against the Holy Spirit
will not be forgiven now is that forever
or I don't understand okay very good
question
sometimes that is referred to as the
unpardonable sin the same verse is
translated or at least presented in some
of the other Gospels as the unpardonable
sin in Jesus it every sin shall be
forgiven man except one and that is the
blasphemy of the Holy Spirit or the
unpardonable sin against the Holy Spirit
now here's what we need to understand
the unpardonable sin isn't and single
sin that a person might commit let me
give you a little bit of a background
the word blasphemy in the Bible in the
New Testament means two things number
one it means claiming titles that belong
to God in other words claiming that I am
all right let me try that move this mic
a little closer here
all right the word blasphemy in the
Bible means two things number one is
claiming to be God or claiming the names
or titles of God the other one is
claiming to be able to forgive sin or
excuse sin
so the Holy Spirit the work of the Holy
Spirit is to convict us of sin but when
a person rejects the convicting of the
Holy Spirit and says you know I don't
need to follow the Holy Spirit I don't
need to do what God's asking me to do
what we are doing is we are sinning
against the Holy Spirit we are rejecting
the voice of the Holy Spirit the Bible
tells us that it's the Holy Spirit that
brings us to repentance so if we keep
rejecting the Holy Spirit well then the
Holy Spirit is not going to be able to
bring us to a point of repentance and if
we don't repent then we can't be
forgiven so the unpardonable sin or the
sin of blasphemy against the Holy Spirit
is when a person continually over an
extended period of time
rejects the holy spirit to the point
where they don't feel sorry for they
sense where they don't ask for
forgiveness where they don't care about
God where they're not interested in
doing anything God is asking them to do
because they've hardened their heart
that's what it means the unpardonable
son sometimes people ask us well maybe I
committed the unpardonable sin and we
have we tell them more good news you
probably wouldn't even worry whether or
not you're committed the unpardonable
sin if you really have committed the
unpardonable sin but the fact that a
person is even wondering means the Holy
Spirit is convicting them so yeah you
don't have to feel that you committed
the unpardonable sin if you're seeking
to do God's will that's proof that the
Holy Spirit is convicting and works in
your heart oh good good well thank you
very much all right great question
thanks for calling who do you have next
we've got Paula from Canada Paula you're
on the air with Bible answers live doing
very well thank you
and your question I think my question is
about the sealing of God's resonant
people at the last period of the close
of the probation
okay so just make it you know clearer
understanding if you could expound a
little bit sure absolutely let me give
you a passage of scripture that talks
about this Revelation chapter 7 talks
about the seal of God and in the book of
Revelation there are two marks or seals
the righteous God's people have the seal
of God the wicked have what's called the
mark of the beast
now the seal of God is something that
the righteous receiving therefore it
it's not a literal mark but it
represents something the Floyd
represents the heart or the character
it's the mind these are those who are
fully surrendered to Christ they are
committed to Jesus they want to do those
things pleasing to Jesus they are sealed
or marked with the Holy Spirit then at
the end of time there will be those who
turn aside from God's commandments to
follow man-made tradition and they're
the ones that end up receiving the mark
of the beast so two distinct groups at
the end of time after these two groups
have been formed and you have one group
with the seal of God and another group
with the mark of the beast then it is
that probation closes in Daniel chapter
12 it says
michael stands up the Great Prince who
stands watch over the sons of thy people
and there will be a time of trouble
worse than the world of his ever seen
but at that time thy people will be
delivered everyone found written in the
book so after the sealing is all
finished then at some point Jesus closes
his high priestly ministry in
preparation for him coming as king of
kings and Lord of lords oh there's so
much I can say about this Paula just
real quick there are three phases to
Christ's ministry he is our sacrifice he
is a priest and he's a king when Jesus
on the earth he came to bear our sins
and died in our place he was our
sacrifice when he ascended to heaven he
is ministering in a heavenly sanctuary
he is our high priest but when he
finishes his work as our high priest he
removes his priestly robe puts on his
kingly robe and he comes back as king of
kings and Lord of lords so when he
finishes the workers priest that's when
probation closes you have the seven last
plagues and then Jesus comes did that
help a little bit and I went through
that fast but you know we do have a
study guide called the seal of God and
we'll be happy to send that to you mayor
of fact you can even read it for free
online if you just go to the amazing
facts website just amazing facts dot
o-r-g and we're gonna try and get
another calling yeah before we run out
of time who do we have next we've got
Joe from Las Vegas Joe you're on the
line with Bible answers alive what is
your question isn't hi Joe we just got a
couple minutes here before I pushed off
the air what's your question time with
the abomination that causes desolation
necessary for the abomination great
question let me quickly address that
before we run out of time are you
referring to Matthew 24 where Jesus says
speaking to his disciples when you see
the abomination of desolation spoken of
by Daniel the prophet stand in the Holy
Place let him there be in Jerusalem flee
in in Judea flee out of the city well
that had a historical application in 70
AD with the destruction of Jerusalem but
there is a spiritual application
remember I mentioned a temple the temple
represents the church so when there is a
power in the church claiming to be God
claiming to be able to
since and forcing people to worship a
certain way in a symbolic or spiritual
sense that is an abomination in the
temple so we're not talking about a
literal building here but we're talking
about the church at the end having the
Antichrist power also known as the
abomination of desolation manifests in
the church and as a result people are
led astray and that's where the mark of
the beast issue comes from that we
mention a little bit earlier well
there's a lot more we can say about that
but you know we do have a study guide
that I think you'll find interesting
dealing with that same subject about the
abomination of desolation it's the mark
of the beast just call for that and
we'll be happy to send it to you our
resource phone number is 883 five six
seven four seven and again you can ask
for the study guide called the mark of
the beast and we'll be happy to send it
to anybody who calls and asks or go to
the amazing facts website just amazing
facts dot o-r-g while I'm looking at the
engineer pastor McKenzie and he's
showing us one minute so we probably
don't have time to take another caller
we won't do justice to they call but
friends we want to thank you so much for
listening tonight and hopefully we got
you thinking a little bit and a whole
goal of this program is to inspire
people to go back to the word to study
it for themselves and we've been
mentioning different resources
throughout the program call us on our
resource phone number if you'd like any
of the free material that we've been
talking about this evening the number is
883 five six seven four seven you can
call that number after the program you
can ask for any of the study guides or
any of the books that we mentioned this
evening and then also go to the amazing
facts website just amazing facts dot
o-r-g there is just a wealth of
information there are videos you can
watch in different Bible topics there is
additional study resources and you can
sign up for the free amazing facts Bible
course it's free let's go to amazing
facts orgy until next week god bless
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
amazing facts through your faithful
support has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-christian locations
in the world beyond the Great Wall the
printing and translation of our books
and video materials are in constant
motion
Daichi Ohio faith oxygen Tian Jia Jia
China - the amazing facts Chinese
language website is now one of our most
visited websites we also translated
thousands of pieces of literature for
these nations what started out as
hundreds of followers is now in the
hundreds of thousands the impact of your
funds invested in sharing the
everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come you
know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word and none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry god bless you I really
wanted to start a new devotional habit
but life got in the way next thing I
know we're a month into the new year and
I'm like what's the point of starting
then I saw 365 amazing answers to big
Bible questions each day is a single
study so you can start anywhere on any
day and not miss a thing their crisp
clear and enlightening get yours today
by calling
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF AG 0 RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]